[Musique]
vincent lagaf pour tout vous dire c'est
vraiment quelqu'un mimi qui fait partie
de notre famille quoi il est il et feel
good
il dégage une empathie il dégage quelque
chose qui fait que voilà il est des
nôtres supporter une partie familiale
enfin pas petits frères soeurs et ou
externe peut soulever des doutes et il
ya un côté fait par huawei frère
là j'ai l'impression de revenir quelques
années en arrière mais finalement on est
dix ans en 2018 avec un nouveau jeu
totalement moderne une création
originale ça j'adore je pense et je
crois en la motivation de vincent lagaf
dans ce programme qui va nous donner
toute l'énergie nécessaire pour aller au
plus haut plus au nord la carrière que
j'ai loupé en fait je voulais jouer au
bowling et mauvaises expériences
atomiques mais lui même
[Musique]
le tombeau